u.s president joe biden has ordered
intelligence officials to deliver a new
report on the origins of the covid19
pandemic within 90 days
biden says u.s intelligence agencies are
divided over whether the virus emerged
from human contact with an affected
animal
or from a laboratory accident a joint
china who study published in march said
that it was highly improbable
that the covet 19 virus reached leaked
from a research lab in wuhan
it concluded that it most likely spread
from bats to humans
via as an and as yet unidentified
intermediary species
and dw's william bluecroft is following
this story for us
william why is president biden calling
for this investigation
at this point hi sumi there's been
growing skepticism in the scientific
community
and in political communities all around
the world about the natural
emergence theory we saw this in a wall
street journal article recently that
showed that
perhaps lab workers at that wuhan lab
went to the hospital at the end of 2019
before china
reported officially that the coronavirus
was here that there was a beginning of
this pandemic
uh there's been a lot of coverage over
the last year uh an open letter from
scientists to the to the journal
science uh questioning the natural
emergence theory wanting more
information on the potential for a lab
accident as the cause of this
um and this is why while the natural
theory has been
the main cause that people have been
supporting for this past year there has
been uh
investigations in this whole year
looking into the possibility of a lab
accident so it's
it's not nothing new but it's getting
new attention now
and of course uh this fits into joe
biden's uh heavy pushback
against china on the world scale whether
it's trade whether it's military
a whole host of things this is one more
aspect of the us positioning itself
against china
but why is this theory that the origin
was perhaps a lab
accident why is it so controversial
well lab accident of course comes with
accountability it it means that someone
was at fault there's liability issues
um you know more than three and a half
million people maybe as many as 10
million or more people
if you count real estimates excess death
estimates have been killed from this
virus so
it's a much more convenient and
politically easier
uh thing to say that this was just that
this was just natural that no one could
have seen this coming that there was
there was nothing we could have done
whereas if this did leak out of a lab
then
of course there is something that maybe
could have been done but it's really
really important to say that even if we
do discover that this was a lab
accident or this was somehow man-made it
doesn't mean that this is some
anti-china conspiracy it doesn't mean
that this was a bio weapon to attack
people
there was legitimate research
coronavirus research going on
at this wuhan lab some of it funded by
the united states by the national
institutes of health
so this would look badly on both china
and the u.s
if we find out that certain precautions
weren't taken if accidents did happen
and it should be noted that accidents do
happen from time to time with these
these kinds of laboratories
and william just quickly how has beijing
responded to all of this
well of course beijing has hit out hard
saying this is just more smoke and
mirrors from the u.s
and it really and beijing is not
necessarily wrong about that
credibility really counts here and the
intelligence community united states
god has gotten a lot of things wrong i
mean the weapons of mass destruction in
iraq
15 20 years ago to name just one major
flaw
so this speaks to why it's so so
important for institutions for
government institutions to play it
straight with facts and to be
transparent so that way when things like
this come around they can be trusted
and their their credibility won't be
called into question like elements
in china that of course have a very deep
interest
to uphold the natural emergence theory
william grewcroft reporting for us there
thank you for bringing us that story